face au déchaînement de la violence les
derniers journalistes internationaux ont
quitté marioupol culliver crack bon jour
on vous retrouve à lviv la grande ville
de l'ouest de l'ukraine vous avez pu
rencontrer des rescapés de marioupol
oui il y a deux personnes ou si vous
voulez un couple et un homme que j'ai
rencontré séparément ici à lviv ils se
connaissaient pas mais il avait des
histoires assez similaire à raconter sur
comment ils sont sortis de marioupol
l'homme est sorti dans une camionnette
avec neuf personnes il m'a montré les
trous dans le toit de sa camionnette le
résultat de nos bus qui est tombée
dessus mais pendant que cet égard et
avant le début du voyage pendant le
voyage personne ne leur a tiré dessus
mais il m'a dit qu'il a vu d'autres
voitures en flammes et qu' il y a des
mines et des obus non explosés le long
de la route donc sortir de marioupol est
extrêmement dangereux les gens le font
les geler le couple m'a dit la même
chose uniquement parce qu'ils estiment
que rester c'est un cru encore plus
dangereux que de sortir et les histoires
de ce qu'ils ont vécu à l'intérieur de
mario polt sont tout simplement horrible
pire que le pire film d'horreur que je
puisse imaginer m'a dit une femme dans
le couple qui qui est sorti avec leur
enfant de 7 ans ils ont aussi raconté
comment l'enfant dessiner à l'aide des
bougies dans le sous sol où il habitait
pendant plusieurs jours parce qu'il n'y
avait pas d'électricité des dessins
relatifs à la guerre et aussi le mot
enfant que les ukrainiens leur avait
instruit les militaires ukrainien leur
avait dit de mettre très clairement sur
la voiture pour alerter qu' il y avait
des enfants à bord de cette voiture
c'était des gens qui étaient évidemment
très traumatisée par ce qui s'est passé
est aussi très très en colère contre non
seulement vladimir poutine mais la
russie toute entière c'est ce qu'ils ont
voulu souligner la situation à kiev à
présent gulliver un bombardement la nuit
dernière a visé un centre commercial sur
place il ne reste absolument rien il ya
eu huit morts est ce qu'on en sait plus
sur ce nouveau drame
je sais seulement qu'il y avait eu
effectivement oui mort c'était un centre
commercial où il y avait notamment un
magasin de la chaîne française leroy
merlin j avais fait des courses moi même
il y a quelques années et maintenant il
y un mouvement en ukraine pour que leroy
merlin se retire de la russie leroy
merlin fait partie des chaînes qui
fonctionne encore en russie et ce sont
les employés ukrainiens eux mêmes de
leroy merlin qui appelle à la chaîne
d'arrêter tout commerce avec la russie
maintenant un employé de leroy merlin et
parmi ces huit morts merci pour ces
précisions gulliver craag depuis lviv
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine le